et passer à travers la vitre ici puis
elle a éraflé le matelas et la atterri
dans le mur juste en face
si on habitait dans la chambre il ya
quelqu'un qui se serait pris ni mal vous
ne verrez pas le visage de cette mère de
famille car deux jours après les coups
de feu
l'émotion est encore forte les motards
se trouvait là quand ils ont tiré
donc ils ont tiré ici dimanche
après-midi elle son mari et une de ses
filles sont dans leur maison dans ce
quartier résidentiel
d'habitude plutôt calme puis tout à coup
des impacts de balles de cette taille
ils ont tiré là là là et puis là haut et
ils ont tiré aussi dans la vitre mon ami
ici vit la famille x pour dire que
en fait il s'était trompé de cible un
message pour se protéger pour éviter que
la scène ne se répète car selon les
premiers éléments de l'enquète ce sont
les anciens propriétaires qui auraient
été visés cette famille elle ne vite ici
que depuis un an on a tout de suite
appelé les gendarmes et on est allé se
cacher au sol toute la famille est
choquée oui on veut plus dormir en bas
la petite jour où ça arrive et elle
voulait pas dormir là on a dû la force
et à dormir avec nous et puis mal an on
va voir un psychologue demain après midi
en famille pour essayer de d'aller mieux
le couple ne compte pas quitter sa
maison de son côté l'enquêté se poursuit
pour tenter d'identifier les deux
tireurs à moto